hey reject nation Greg Alva here Dan
Seibert is back what dan from that cyber
channel moved six and a half hours away
like a jerk because he's engaged it's
because Ali's expensive dude went to e3
and then immediately hopped over onto
here after being and that craziness of a
crowd it's my first e3 and it's an it's
been insane so far well hey man I want
to hear nothing more than just that yeah
also this is the one shirt I would wear
whenever I was with you so I've waited
all week to wear this shirt and where's
my Mario hats - odds in my car let
speaking of Mario we're gonna watch the
trailer for the Super Smash Brothers
ultimate everyone is here trailer before
we do that I want to shout out Dan's
fiancee Alyssa on her Channel Alyssa be
crazy over I always would be crazy we
live streamed our reaction to the
Microsoft conference so if you want to
see a 31 year old loses damn mind over a
Devil May Cry 5 and if you want to see a
28 year old lose his mind
watch short of our video seriously go to
Alyssa's channel and check that out link
in the description box for you guys full
disclosure because we're not liars at
the real rejects unlike those Tyrone
Magnus's Dan did get it play this game
already so this won't be entirely
surprising for him this morning I
basically went straight to the
conference I didn't get a chance to
watch everything I'm finally getting to
see like how it was all revealed because
I was in the car when all of this okay I
haven't been
properly hyped I haven't see this is
brand new to me and I actually love
supers match oh boy
[Music]
with samus's big curve a
[Music]
who's that no actually pretty ol two
arrows to everything it like it looks
the same but it looks different it looks
very well-polished
it looks very polished yet something
different the frame rate that I'm
actually kind of pumped on that so
that's the link between worlds skin
[Music]
you too so I wanna go catatonic they're
all back
Pikachu that's my go-to player right
there because he's the most annoying she
I forget where ice climbers or Jam we're
back they were gone in the last one in
their back oh I forgot about that whose
inkling from splatoon she that's new
Falcon zero suit samus squirt OH
vibrator yes okay okay love nests Ryu
[Music]
like a chocolate cloud cloud beanbag
cloud go everyone snake wasn't in the
last one right yeah the whole thing
about this one every character that has
ever been in smashes in it Oh everyone
oh thank god
so snakes back where's Mega Man oh soon
maybe I don't know it really needs to be
an antenna cinematic universe
right you got dr. Mario Jacques mom kept
it dark bed and patina
pour in and he approached me I intended
- and lengthen here and ugly what yeah
all three links there's three links be
final little Mac I love Mac Mac
so
Wow that is there's mega man with proto
man in I mean
oh right these two holy cow that's
there's like what 60 some character oh
goodness
everyone I was a little bit unsure how
to like respond to one that was going on
actually something okay yeah I've seen
these guys cool where's the different
stuff and then you said it in the middle
of them like oh that's what's going on
yeah they're all over here yeah this
takes my jet you know things are my
favorite smashed burgers characters
really there's the Metal Gear Solid's my
favorite game of all time so having
snake back is exciting for me personally
this is a lot of people this is like
infinity war but for super smash man
getting to the conference and like
quickly like catching up with everything
before I started doing stuff and going
with wait hold up every character is in
it that was an announcement made today
yeah it was that every characters in
every character that was ever in
smashing in it and there's actually one
character that wasn't in that trailer
who Ridley Ridley he is samus's lover
Ridley is - Sammis like Bowser is -
Mario so they're lovers he's a giant
pterodactyl samus is in today it's fine
you're making it weird you be able to
play like yous all them right away
because I know sometimes you have to
unlock some of these downloads what I
imagine what's gonna happen you'll have
your starter characters and then just
like every other smash you slowly unlock
them by playing the game whether it has
to play so many multiplayer ones or
accomplish this event so you're still
gonna have to unlock everyone they
haven't said anything about DLC will the
be DLC probably that would be cool if
they did deal I mean if the hype of this
game is everyone is here and more smart
to do deal see it would be smart but
also at the same time with everyone
being in it massive hero Sakurai big
brains behind all of this he is a very
tired smash oh that's a very exhausted
cuz he over works himself and the idea
is like he put all of these characters
in it so we have
the everyone in shut-the-hell-up is
basically what this is statement is fair
fair point I can't wait to drive six and
a half hours to play this with you yeah
cuz I don't on a switch the only reason
I would get a switch is to get super
smash it's the one consistent Nintendo
game I actually play like a chance to
play it it's very fast-paced but it's
very smooth it feels really good to play
is the background as overwhelming as the
last one because the last one I thought
the background was so I mean it's it's
basically still the same this is crazy
it's still just as crazy we played a
couple of the new stages there's a new
breath of the wild talent level bets I
don't imagine I'll be using too often
it's a little too cramped and crazy but
the splatoon levels pretty fun the
Inklings really interesting to use and
ridley is overpowered if you want to
know who to play play Ridley he's broken
if there's a game to pick up for the
holiday season I can already tell you
this is the game this is the game it's
better party game than mario party all
right guys well who's your favorite
Super Smash Brothers character to use
please choose Zelda everyone chooses
Zelda yeah she's everyone's go-to
favorite she's pretty that's not my
abuser she's the best technically you
guys subscribed to the reject nation to
click that notification bell check out
dance I Birds Channel that cyber channel
it's totally worth it something to do
with video games and check out Alyssa be
crazies channel because they have their
thing up about Devil May Cry 5 it's a go
checker we're a team that's that's what
you matrimony get put a ring on it